people might not believe in heaven so
much anymore people might not go to
church so much anymore in fact religious
belief is declining but this is what's a
little weird belief in hell is
increasing according to a recent Pew
research report
62 percent of American adults believe in
hell
that's up from 58 percent in 2014. and
we're seeing this in the pop culture
we're seeing Sam Smith dance around like
the devil we're seeing all sorts of
occult imagery
I'm not terribly surprised by this
people might think it's a little weird
to believe in hell if you don't believe
in heaven and you don't believe in
Redemption you don't believe in God but
I don't think it's all that weird people
see evidence of hell all around them you
see evidence of hell when you turn on
the news good stuff doesn't make the
news bad stuff makes the news it's very
difficult to deny evil